I was exactly where I wanted to be close
enough to kill assassin Chou John was
trained by none other than Ezio Auditore
and she really wants a box the artifact
in the box is irrelevant it's just a
MacGuffin that sends her off on a 2-d
stealth adventure called Assassin's
Creed chronicles China that looks
absolutely stunning but ultimately comes
off as a mildly enjoyable mark of the
ninja wannabe if a game must rest on
being pretty then at least chronicles
makes the most of it gorgeous moon rises
and lush cherry blossoms have the
natural smudges and brushstrokes you
would expect to see from the Chinese
masters each scene comes to life with an
inviting softness which makes it
disappointing that the story doesn't
build this world in any meaningful way
as Xiao Jun you move through these
spaces sneaking past patrolling guards
and avoiding their vision cones they
can't see more than 20 feet in front of
their own faces and will not notice you
at all when they engage in conversation
with each other
avoidance means slipping behind a pillar
hanging from a front-facing ledge
crawling along a ceiling or tumbling
into a pile of hay sometimes you toss
your rope dart towards an overhang and
swing towards or away from the camera
and into a different layer chronicles
makes good use of these layers giving
its best levels a terrific sense of
depth you spend more time however
navigating past the guards that bar your
way by sneaking around them
assassinating them or by directly
confronting them
it is in silent assassination that
Chronicle stays truest to the series
when you plunge your hidden dagger into
an enemy from behind you hear an eerie
crunch and blood seeps across the corpse
and dissipates performing an
assassination while hanging from above
is even more enjoyable thanks to the way
Xiao Jun points her blade downward as
she falls later on you can sprint
forward and slide into unaware guards
which makes for a rewarding combination
of momentum and violence the game awards
you the most points for staying hidden
yet it's in the pure stealth that
chronicles flaws most often surface in
any stealth game there is intrinsic
reward and staying out of sight yet over
the game's four hour or so running time
the challenge rarely grows you earn
upgrades to your stealth repertoire as
you progress but there's no sense of
rising tension the stealth puzzles never
become all that challenging and a few
ideas like birds and dogs that give you
away are too rare to add much anxiety to
sneaking
in time you discover ways to exploit the
ai's limitations rushing out of guards
view if you alert all of them and
waiting to return until they resume
patrolling just a few seconds later you
have gadgets like throwing knives at
your disposal but you rarely need to use
them in creative ways since the same
basic strategies usually work in any
given situation and occasionally the
game doesn't know how to respond to your
reactions and glitches out guards might
freeze in place until you move out of
hiding for example then there's combat
combats never been Assassin's Creed
strong suit but swordplay has always had
an easy-to-understand rhythm and
chronicles fending off guards is hardly
fun it's possible to escape with your
life if you're really careful but the
entire affair is clumsy there's no
cadence to enemy behavior and the
controls are fiddly direct confrontation
is best avoided as you can imagine in a
stealth game ironically this stealth
games finest moments arrive when you
escape looming danger such as a blazing
fire these sequences of the closest
Chronicles comes to delivering the
series signature free running you vault
over obstacles and slide into
shell-shocked guards cutting them down
as you sprint ahead it's a lively
diversion in a game that is otherwise
mostly devoid of momentum you know the
end is coming but there was no more
excitement in that finale than there was
in the opening minutes chronicles
passive pacing is a shame because the
pieces are mostly strong but once you
get past the game's looks and get
accustomed to its 2d stealth
there's too little to keep you moving
forward assassin's creed chronicles
China is as lovely as a postcard but
when you're a tourist you need more than
just pretty sights thinking that killing
me will achieve
Eddie's killing just one of you will not
give me defendants I seek you are the
first of the Tigers to fall but you will
not be the last
you